avevo inizialmente preparato una
presentazione in stile powerpoint di
quelle che di solito faccio quando vado
in giro per il mondo poi ha buttato
tutto perché penso che noi oggi abbiamo
bisogno più che di vedere di ascoltare
se ascoltiamo di più di quanto facciamo
forse il peso delle parole ci arriva
meglio avevo deciso anche di puntare su
alcune delle cose che insomma mi sarebbe
stato facile farlo da da linguista cose
sulle quali avrei potuto dire anche cose
specialistiche poi ho deciso di puntare
su alcuni aspetti della mia esperienza
personale perché io credo che tutti noi
ci portiamo dietro quello che siamo
e allora qui racconterò alcuni di questi
episodi e poi cercherò un po di
costruire qualche percorso su quello che
può significare oggi coraggio
una volta ho ritenuto di dover
pubblicare un articolo
era un articolo per una rivista
scientifica che dirigo era stato scritto
da una studentessa che l'aveva ricavato
dalla sua tesi di laurea aveva fatto un
giro incredibile di passaggi nessuno lo
aveva voluto pubblicare molti lo avevano
lodato io l'ho pubblicato e dava conto
degli strafalcioni di alcuni colleghi
accademici che commettono errori come
tutti noi tutti commettiamo errori e
dobbiamo forse farne tesoro
però non dobbiamo tacere quando non
vogliamo che questi errori si sappiano
ecco questo già un atto di coraggio
un'altra volta ero preside capito sulla
mia scrivania un plico che conteneva un
estratto di manuale in uso nella mia
università quando cominciai a leggere
non credevo a quello che leggevo perché
quel manuale in uso perso la mia
università scritto da un docente della
mia facoltà conteneva giudizio offese
inaccettabili
cercato di capire se poteva essere il
momento giusto per prendere la decisione
giusta e l'ho fatto potevo perdere però
ce l'ho fatta ecco tante volte abbiamo
letto che il coraggio alberga dove
alberga la paura che è la paura innesca
il coraggio io ho piuttosto sperimentato
un altra cosa
un atto che richiedeva coraggio mi ha
messo alla prova e ha fatto nascere in
me tante di quelle paure che mi hanno
aiutato a crescere umanamente e
professionalmente emotivamente
quell'articolo l'articolo di cui parlare
uscito il professore è stato inchiodato
alle sue responsabilità e io ne ho
guadagnato ne ha guadagnato incoscienza
meno coscienza civile se non
professionale
ogni porta abbiamo avuto paura di non
farcela ogni volta ne sono però uscito
convinto che quella paura potesse
rinforzare le mie convinzioni non ci si
libera di una cosa evitando la ma
soltanto attraversandola questo l'ha
scritto cesare pavese nelle mestiere di
vivere fosse il mestiere più difficile
del mondo
la viltà e qui penso così che tutti noi
possiamo riflettere su quegli
attraversamenti di significati che
passano per per alcune parole per il
loro opposto io su questo vorrei
soffermarmi aiutarmi aiutarvi a
riflettere la vita non è soltanto
lasciarsi sopraffare senza reagire
il coraggio non è soltanto combattere
senza mai mollare la viltà può essere
semplicemente salire su un piedistallo e
non aveva nessuna intenzione di scendere
e il coraggio magari può essere non
voler salire ha fatto su quel
piedistallo viltà vuol dire
compromettersi se diamo peso alle parole
anche soltanto una sola volta coraggio e
non cedere mai alle pressioni mai a
ricatti e qui diamo peso alle parole
pensiamo a quanto è importante oggi la
negoziazione negoziare importante oggi è
importante negoziare un idea
negoziare un valore negoziare un sapere
perché viviamo nell'era delle
negoziazioni alle negoziazioni è un
dialogo una forma importante di dialogo
se rinunciamo a negoziare abbiamo
rinunciato a noi stessi prima ancora che
all'attivazione di un dialogo
ebbene le parole spesso ci fanno scherzi
da una parte c'è la negoziazione
dall'altra parte c'è il negozio se il
negozio ci disonorano volta ci disonora
per sempre ecco la viltà e comportarsi
forse prendendo spunto da una storia
vecchia è sempre bella da raccontare con
potassico come un nano ai piedi di un
gigante saliamo ci torniamo a salire
sulle spalle di quel gigante talvolta si
dice sì il coraggio può smuovere le
montagne ma se noi ogni tanto su una
montagna ci arrampichiamo fosse che
abbiamo quanto è più faticoso ancora di
ri sono secondo me anche gli pseudo
intellettuali organici ne abbiamo tanti
sono coraggiosi invece gli intellettuali
scomodi
vengo da milano dove si è parlato di
steve jobs e mi è venuta in mente il suo
slogan pensiamo differente che non è
solo uno slogan non è solo un motto
osservare il mondo con occhi diversi e
reagire all'omologazione il pensiero
differente passa proprio per reazione a
quella omologazione che quegli occhi
vorrebbe che noi li chiudessimo ogni
volta se il cammino della viltà e
accompagnato da un rimpianto quello del
coraggio può essere accompagnato anche
da un rimorso talvolta accompagnato da
vino rosso ma ha un rimpianto non si può
rimediare ora il nostro sì c'è chi non
ci vede c'è chi finge di non vederci c'è
chi ci vede ma non ci guarda c'è chi ci
guarda ma non ci vede quando qualcuno
comincerà a vederci con tutti i nostri
difetti con tutti i nostri errori
allora forse possiamo essere sicuri di
aver intrapreso la via giusta e quel
qualcuno quando avrà ignorato i nostri
difetti e quando avrà ignorato i nostri
errori
quando avrà dimenticato le nostre
contraddizioni
forse si sarà convinto che se lo abbiamo
fatto e qui la forza delle parole è
davvero forte
se se lo abbiamo fatto e perché siamo
usciti dagli
se siamo usciti dagli schemi lo abbiamo
fatto anche per spianarlo per aprirgli
la strada
solo allora secondo me potremmo forse
oppure non so io vorrei chiamarla
addirittura morale non se ne sente più
parlare per reagire alla fiera delle
complicità perché in molti casi ci
troviamo di fronte a nocera delle
complicità bellissima questa frase di
hermann hesse che ha scritto ci sono
persone che vivono nei sogni ma non nei
loro
ecco chi vive i sogni altrui vive una
vita più facile perché una vita vissuta
di riflesso chi vive in prima persona
certamente si deve aspettare che con i
sogni arrivino anche gli incubi con i
successi arrivino anche le sconfitte
cocenti con gli alti con i pochi alti
arrivino anche i tantissimi bassi e la
legge del cuore la parola coraggio è
imparentata con la parola cuore non
dimentichiamolo mai perché coraggio alla
stessa radice etimologica di cuore
perché legata una parola latina che
derivava da cuore ecco non dimentichiamo
mai che il coraggio più che con la mente
ci fa ragionare ci fa fare i conti con
il nostro cuore è la legge del cuore non
possiamo farci niente
una volta che abbiamo però dimostrato di
mettercela tutta
di non esserci risparmiati agli occhi
del mondo
allora forse non serviranno più nei
premi nei riconoscimenti ufficiali se
mai saranno venuti perché il mondo ci
restituirà quello che gli avremmo dato
amor ch'a nullo amato amar perdona
ce lo ha insegnato il nostro grande
padre dante quel mondo se noi l'abbiamo
tanto amato doveva march per forza e
quei pochi che ci avranno ignorato cev
hanno snobbato c'erano vituperato fosse
torneranno alla vita che hanno preso in
prestito e che ci resteranno per sempre
grazie